اعلنت قوات فاجنر من طرف واحد اكمال
السيطره على مدينه باخمت بعد ان وصلت الى
اواخر المدينه حسب الفيديوهات التي
اظهرتها وننتظر في هذه اللحظه وفي هذه
الساعات ان يعني تعلن وتعرض فيديوهات
جديده كان من المفروض ان تعلن في هذه
اللحظات فيديوهات جديده قال بان
الفيديوهات لم تصل بسبب ضعف الضغط
والانترنت في تلك المنطقه لكن بالتفصيل
منذ ليله امس وقوات فاجنر تقوم بعمليات
عسكريه هجوميه ضد المنطقه الغربيه التي
يتمركز فيها الجيش الاوكراني من مدينه
باخموتكان الحديث عن حوالي كيلو متر متبقي
تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني تقدم في
الساعات الليليه الجيش الروسي او المقصود
قوات فاجنر حوالي 500 متر وكان متبقي 600
متر تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه وقال بان
السيطره تم تمام الساعه الثانيه عشره ظهرا
اي اكمال السيطره حتى اخر المدينه هناك
ساحه تدعى ساحه سمالوط او ساحه الطائره
بعد البنايات الشاهقه واظهرت فيديوهات
لقوات اوكرانيه تنسحب مرتزقه يتحدثون
بلغات اجنبيه منهم جورجيين كما اظهرت ايضا
فيديوهات
لاسرى من الجانب الاوكراني كل هذه
الفيديوهات ابراهيم على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
لم تعلن روسيا رسميا حتى الان السيطره
الجيش الروسي لم يعلن وحتى السلطات
المحليه في دانيتك هنا لم تعلن السيطره
على